ils n'ont pas encore été livrés à
l'armée ukrainienne mais déjà Moscou
voir rouge les avions de chasse F16
promenaient à Kiev par Washington
constitue une menace sérieuse selon la
Russie
nous allons considérer le sol fait que
les forces armées ukrainiennes et de tel
système comme une menace de la part de
l'Occident dans le domaine du nucléaire
la Russie ne peut ignorer la capacité de
ses appareils à transporter des charges
nucléaires
cette déclaration intervient alors que
l'Ukraine a annoncé mardi avoir formé
une coalition de 11 pays afin de former
ces pilotes aux avions F16 une annonce
faites lors du sommet de l'OTAN à
Vilnius pendant lequel les pays
occidentaux ont réitéré leur soutien
militaire hacker le message de ce sommet
des alliés de l'OTAN avec les nouvelles
annonces de missiles de croisière à
longue portée de véhicules blindés
supplémentaires dotés de système de
défense aérienne plus avancé et de la
formation des pilotes de F16 et que nous
les soutenons pour libérer des
territoires afin qu'ils aient une
position plus forte à la table des
négociations longtemps réclamé par le
président ukrainien la livraison de ces
avions de fabrication américaine a été
autorisée en mai par le président des
États-Unis pour l'heure on ne sait
toujours pas combien d'avions seront
livrés à l'Ukraine ni quand belle
annonce du début de la formation des
pilotes Ukrainiens sont ces commencé au
Danemark le mois prochain pourrait
donner un indice il faudra au moins 6
mois pour que les pilotes reçoivent une
formation accélérée au pilotage DFC